Now that you know what a polynomial is, we're going to talk briefly about a word
that we use to characterize a given term in a polynomial. The degree of a term.
Now, the degree of a term is equal to the sum of all the exponents of all of the
variable that are in that term. So if we have a term like negative 4x cubed,
then the degree of this term is 3. Since we have an exponent of 3 for the only
variable that's in the term x. Another way we could say this is that this is a
3rd degree term. Now if, in contrast, we have a term like 6y to 7th, z to the
4th, the degree is 11 or we could also say this is a 11th degree term. Now the
degree is 11 here, because for a first variable we see we have a power of 7 and
for the second variable we have a power of 4. y and z are the only two variables
in this expression, so the degree is equal to the sum of their powers, 7 plus 4
equals 11.